to tell you the truth I was gonna wait
until this arc ended before I began
commentating on it but with these last
few chapters it's given me more than
enough to praise and to take issue with
I put up a poll on my Twitter asking you
guys if you were enjoying how this arc
was playing out and the vast majority of
you seemed to like it the comment
section however was rife with debate and
discussion between both sides so let me
know what you think here on YouTube
click above but what have people been
arguing about well for the last eight
months from where Dragon Ball super bro
Lee's movie left off to Tara's manga
continued the story of Dragon Ball for
all of us fans to faithfully follow in a
brand-new never-before-seen saga it
introduces new characters interesting
stakes and powers all the while
reintroducing elements that made older
fans like myself smile with nostalgia
however with that said the last few
chapters have injected a lot of
questionable elements that I really
wanted to address today so let's dive
into Dragon Ball super is new material
the new galactic patrol saga from Akira
Toriyama and Toyo Terra it's time to
take a look at morrow the villainous
eater of worlds and is troubled chapters
[Music]
why not the back before we dive into the
issues I have with this arc I want to
make known that I found this section
much easier to read than others in the
past and it's injected quite a few
elements into the story that I've
enjoyed or at the very least found
interesting I love the concept of morale
not necessarily from a visual
perspective at the moment I am more
concerned with what his character offers
the story and the action of this battle
shown in the Trouble Dragon Balls found
itself in is that in order to create
believable tension between characters in
the past it's needed to create villains
that look stronger than the last which
becomes quite tiresome and formulaic
after a short period of time morale
flips this trend on its head instead of
the power that guided over the course of
the series being used to overcome the
villain in this story it's actually a
disadvantage to them as a result would
ever Goku and Vegeta come into contact
with Mauro we genuinely don't know what
they can do to overcome him because
everything they've relied on in the past
to get the job done is literally fueling
their foe with it taking everything
they've got to survive I'm not in a
contrived way either in a
a believable way simply because of how
Morrow's designed as a character he
essentially removes that I just got a
punch him harder mantra that has clung
to Dragon Balls story like a parasites
in Z it's a wonderful concept that
serves a story well I think Morel as a
character however isn't much to write
home about he's pretty much King Piccolo
but on a cosmic scale with that said
however because they lean into this
massive sense of scope and scale it
makes him much more intimidating now I
don't dislike him I just don't think
from a personality point of view he's
very interesting where Frieza would have
had me turning each page wondering what
he might say next I find myself more
often than not waiting for Morrow to
stop talking that said I will wait until
the story ends before I dive into his
character properly but for now he seems
sort of vapid furthermore on the writing
front I've heard a lot of folks
criticize the beginning of this arc
based purely on it not dealing with
stakes as higher as the prior one this
is an issue Dragon Ball Z introduced by
constantly upping the ante with each
subsequent arc protect your family
protect the earth protect the universe
protect the universe and the heavens I
genuinely think that's a losing formula
even from a pacing perspective there's
this expression that you can't
appreciate the light without the dark in
other words everything needs peaks and
valleys in order to generate the desired
emotional reaction we can't always be at
a ten outta ten hype it needs to build
up to that if we are constantly pushing
the ceiling up and up and up all the
time then eventually we become
desensitized to what is at stake that is
if we haven't already
my point is the stakes our scope of a
particular story only matters as much as
the emotional resonance we have for the
characters involved for instance if Tony
created a villain that would instantly
erase all of Goku's friends that would
be just as emotionally devastating as
someone destroying the universe simply
put one death is a tragedy one million
deaths is a statistic when the stakes
become absurdly high it starts to become
increasingly more difficult to
appreciate the scope of the consequences
simply throwing more at the situation
isn't good storytelling so this galactic
patrol Ark decided to focus on the
internal conflict of the namekian people
and Vegeta I greatly appreciate it
because now I have something to root for
I genuinely enjoy the notion
Vegeta feels tremendous remorse for his
past actions on Namek resulting in his
character feeling compelled to go above
and beyond for these people in danger
this is a wonderful fresh and believable
story for Vegeta to partaken and I'm
here for it I've also seen people upset
that the namekians Savior or fuse
namekian warrior was taken down so
easily by Mauro personally I don't see
this as an issue in the slightest in the
tournament of power such beings already
existed in universe 6
additionally in chapter 45 they already
had a large portion of their energy
stolen to suggest Mauro is capable of
what he did against the namekian warrior
isn't really a tough pill to swallow
when you consider that even when he was
unhealthy he was still going toe to toe
against a Super Saiyan God and not even
all the namekians were involved in that
fusion in fact know that I think about
it I'd go as far as to say that if they
did stand a chance against him it would
be incredibly inconsistent however that
is just a minor gripe people have had
now on to bigger criticisms another big
gripe people seem to have with the story
is miracies ability to outmaneuver a
Super Saiyan 3 Goku this leads to a host
of questions about his abilities and how
they formed which as of writing this
video has not been explained I have
several questions
naturally this leads all of us to think
surely he could have helped with Frieza
or sell or Buu it is established in
chapter 43 that he's not hiding his
power but is incredibly agile and quick
this was while Goku and Vegeta were in
their base states this didn't bother
anyone as far as I can remember however
if you put mirrors in a one-on-one
situation where Goku is actively trying
a substantial amount mirrors his
abilities seem like much more of a
character contrivance than an actual
character trait and what I mean by that
is due to the absurd power achieved
through tremendous effort throughout the
series Goku and his friends have been
recognized time and time again even by
the gods as being exceptional
individuals for achieving the power they
have for myris to appear with these
abilities without any explanation seems
unreasonable for an audience to
unanimously accept given how power and
speed correlated in Dragon Ball and even
Dragon Ball super
when Mira suggests that he can't stand
against Mauro it comes across as more of
a plot convenience than a believable
thing
happen within the story for this
character especially when you consider
that characters in the past even if they
were primarily quick always had
overwhelming power to correlate even if
you take extreme examples like Dragon
Ball super is dispo whose entire gimmick
was that he was incredibly quick he
still possessed the ability to utilize
that speed in order to outmatch much
stronger opponents like Frieza all in
all it just seems incredibly contrived
that mirus can teach Goku ultra instinct
and outmaneuver Super Saiyan 3 in ways
that people like Wiest can't however the
most egregious and Glary example of bad
writing in this story so far surfaced in
chapter 50 when Mauro revealed his third
wish towards the end of the 48th chapter
three wishes are granted tomorrow and
his companion the first restore
Cranberry to perfect health
the second restore Mauro to his full
power and the third is kept secret
this made Mauro much more interesting to
me not just because of his power but
also because I enjoy the idea of a
villain that held his cards close to his
chest one that would have a great plan
on a cosmic scale and because he had his
ego in check didn't feel the need to
monologue his plan away to the audience
and he rose organically creating tension
while carving out his own unique
identity that's why this cliffhanger
worked so well when it dropped for me
the idea that a villain had made a wish
with the Dragon Balls but didn't let us
know what that wish was is exactly the
kind of surprise I'd live for in
storytelling so much so that I was
surprised something like this hadn't
already been attempted before in Dragon
Ball it's so simple yet so effective I
love this running technique as it's a
wonderful way to build tension the best
example of this I can think of can be
seen with attack on Titans key to the
basement with Aaron's basement key and
Mauro's third wish
the writer is making a promise to us the
audience that whatever is revealed will
be worth it and change everything for
this technique to be successful it needs
to create the aha moment when it's
revealed the viewers must think of
course that makes so much sense now
fueling the story with a freshness only
a satisfying well thought-out reveal can
provide needless to say I was excited to
see what was in store for me the rest of
the chapter went on
by teasing the third wish the entire
next chapter proceeds on by its teased
again as these months pass on by we the
audience are left to speculate at what
creative and unpredictable wish morale
might have made and what ramifications
it might have in store for the story
moving forward then chapter 50 drops for
whatever reason for some
incomprehensible inconceivable
nonsensical reason Mauro decided to
release all the prisoners from the
Galactic prison he could have wished for
anything and he decided to do that let
me tell you why this bothers me this
wasn't a surprise there was no aha
moment no point where we led to believe
that morale valued anyone other than
himself no point could we ever have
guessed that it was going to be planned
this way and that's the trick of the
secret box in creative writing in attack
on Titan it's possible to figure out
that what is inside the basement and
when it's revealed it changes our
perspective on the entire story the only
reason we don't guess what's inside the
basement is because of the clever
storytelling that builds up to that
moment again it creates an expectation
and subverts that in a very satisfying
way dragonballs didn't build any tension
it didn't create any expectation and its
obverse it nothing it just sort of
happened why did it need to be a
surprise attack on Titans basement scene
is satisfying because it makes complete
sense it doesn't contradict anything and
gives us answers in an enormous ly
satisfying way all at once because
Morrow's third wish seems almost random
with no foreshadowing or meaning behind
it we are faced with a hugely
unsatisfying conclusion to the surprise
it's kind of like your parents telling
you that you have this big surprise to
look forward to for Christmas in October
and then when two months pass by it's
Christmas morning and you open a box to
find socks the mundanity and
lifelessness of this wish made the
occasion worse than before the wish was
even made if this had not been framed in
such a secretive mysterious way I bet no
one would have even batted an eyelash
but instead it was used to build fake
tension I see a lot of people praising
this as a great way to get other
characters involved like piccolo Gohan
and tension hun but frankly I don't care
the outcome of a bad surprises if it's a
bad surprise that has an upside for
other characters that it shouldn't have
been a surprise in the first place it
should have just been delivered straight
there was no need for this to be a
mystery at all and only served to
disappoint a large portion of the
audience with all of that said however I
think this arc has more good than bad to
offer the series the only reason the bad
stands out so prominently in this arc
falls onto how these moments are written
into it the head writing contrivance
ease can slip through the cracks if they
are handled with subtle care but all the
major issues people have with this story
are such because the story so
prominently displays them for all to see
I love the concept of a character like
Mauro despite his somewhat bland
character motivation I love that
characters like vous and Vegeta are
featured so prominently in the story in
a very believable and natural way I'm
happy that namet made a comeback and
forced to yotaro to ease up on his use
of grey tones and even his paneling is
clear in places and not so much in many
others but I'll take what I can get I
want to dive deeper into this story
later on taking an in-depth look at
Marlowe's character specifically however
I'm gonna wait until the story is
complete before I do that the Galactic
Patrol saga is interesting it has its
ups and it's downs and despite having
quite a few troubled chapters I think
it's still a fun ride thanks for
watching
[Music]
you